33 years as the title sponsor of the ATT
Pebble Beach pro-am 5000 fans receive
limited-edition bobbleheads of jordan
Spieth commemorating his 2017 AT&T
Pebble Beach pro-am victory 80 sponsor
jordan Spieth since 2014 is bagged caddy
towel umbrella all featuring the AT&T
logo and we welcome in jordan Spieth
what do you think of your a bobble head
yeah well it's uh we tried to put
Michael on it but he thought that your
caddy yeah we thought we he thought that
his friends would make fun of him so he
he'd kind of Elstad that idea but it's
cool it's really cool you know we it's
great to be back here and it's one of
the more unique trophies and in golf and
so to be on that 18th green with all my
sponsors you know it just was kind of a
fitting one last year that was how are
you as a caddy when's the last time you
actually I think decent I think that's
one of the only other jobs I could
probably do I can't really instruct but
I think I keep caddy I'm pretty
insightful on the course trying to
figure out all the details
what about carrying that big bag yeah I
think I'd be I think I'd be okay with
that I'd struggle a little with I'm a
little stubborn I think you can't really
be stubborn as a caddy would you get mad
if somebody didn't take your advice yeah
maybe the problem yeah yeah you can't
throw a fit out there now and and I'd
hold a grudge but you and Mike you have
a good relationship yeah but he has to
he's got to be the one that bends a
little bit more right right yeah I mean
he has to kind of feel out how
comfortable I am in certain situations
with different shots going for a green
versus you know the risk/reward he's got
to kind of feel out how the rounds been
going and in my kind of communication
with him on how comfortable I am so it's
there's there's a lot more to it than
carrying the sticks out here for sure
he does a great job one of my favorite
shots that you have had in your entire
career had nothing to do with a golf
club you you gave the cup check yeah we
can relate that was all right we're like
did you see what the speech did yeah he
gave his caddy a cup check well in the
best part too is you know Michaels he's
a moseys an emotional guy and at the
time you know he's just still got tears
in his eyes
I'm so I know it I knew it was a perfect
opportunity I go up I go for the high
five and he's just sitting there he's
like oh man yeah and it just was so wide
open I mean it could you toyed with him
back in yeah I think it was I think it
was Dan Hicks it was like oh we actually
slowed it down we broke it down on the
show oh yeah just to let people know how
you you did it I mean it was it was
brilliant that was strategic that's yeah
that's a little concerning that you
wanted this I mean yeah hopefully you
can't see - no no this is what we do
with golf you know we break down Kupchak
absolutely yeah yeah but did you did you
hear from your parents on something like
that
no no I my I think we had a few other
things to talk about
oh good but that's what my buddies were
excited about they were excited about
the code yeah Mike Congrats hey by the
way great yo Mikey like where'd you
watch the Super Bowl in Phoenix we had a
tournament there and I get you know the
tournament's crazy yeah and so my
friends embrace the opportunity to take
the easy flights from Dallas to Phoenix
and I rent a house we all have a good
time and this is our second year
watching the Super Bowl there and we've
got two pretty good Super Bowls at the
house and who are you rooting for I you
know I grew I'm a Dallas Cowboys fan so
I'm that little dot outside of New
England that was rooting for New England
I'm sorry that wasn't you no that wasn't
rooting for the Eagles yeah so I was and
I'm a huge Tom Brady fan and I've gotten
to play golf and interact with him and
so I was rooting for him to get it there
so how good is Brady as a golfer he's
actually really good player he's he's
he's less than a five just as
competitive as you see on the few give
you a creep does he talk try uh if he's
winning you know when he's not he's the
guy that you see on the sidelines with
kind of that look there's like you know
and he's but it's yeah it's a fun
experience he's it's it's just amazing
talking to you know and just getting to
ask for advice from someone like because
he had so much success early in his
career
you know there's first few Super Bowls
and then kind of just you know how to
manage that how to
keep pushing yourself how to how to
continue to work hard towards new goals
you know for him it's kind of chasing a
ghost and that's just something that's
only a few people have really ever tried
to do that in sports and that's you know
something that a few guys have mastered
to your Tigers and your butt but
nobody's
there's no booklet that says this is how
you're supposed to deal with early
success right which is why if you find
somebody who's done it the right way
take advantage and see if they're open
to offering that kind of advice and he
has been you know when you play with
these guys you play with Jordan I have
yeah how would Jordan talks trash uh
yeah you know he's more you know listens
to music and plays fast he's not as big
of a trash talker so he's listening to
men I guess he is yeah yeah I mean his
he's he's always got a fun crew and
they're playing music loud yeah and how
did you fare I think I I three putted
the last hole and he he had me as his
dog like I was you know I was his I was
his partner and I lost him against
whoever we're planning oh yeah I need I
need I need I need to be on his team
again I need to get you know help get
his money back yeah I need to get his
money back we're talking to Jordan
speith how close were you to maybe
making baseball your career instead of
golf um I mean I wasn't I wasn't that
good but my dad played in college and I
was I was a left-handed pitcher as a
left-handed pitcher you don't have to
throw it you know 95 as long as you got
some some weird stuff some Jamie Moyer
type stuff yeah that's my dad pitched
against him in high school actually so
he always used to kind of relate us to
and yeah but I was probably 12 or 13 and
I started to really like the individual
aspect of golf and seeing the you know
the trials and the airs and and how to
learn from both of them and just it's
just easier to see the results from the
practice you put in when you know you
you don't get it's like it's like
watching a you know a Kershaw and
Scherzer matchup where they really are
controlling that much of the game you
know there's not gonna be a whole lot of
run but you miss that interaction with
another athlete because you're sure I
mean you're playing against the field as
opposed to I'm pitching against you or
I'm hitting against you right yeah I do
I miss the interaction match plays fun
the one-on-one golf the few times we get
it but I do miss team sports a lot you
know we get one event a year really
where we get team sports and and the
Ryder Cup and Presidents Cup and that's
that's a lot of fun for us best athlete
in the family is who my little brother
yeah he played professional playing
professional basketball right now he's
sick so he was at Brown it was at Brown
so mom and dad were athlete yeah yeah
but your younger brothers the better
athlete yeah I think so yeah I would uh
he's the better overall athlete for sure
can he take him off at any time no he's
uh
don't be ridiculous what he's a good
player but he's six six a lefty you know
and he's normally plays with clubs that
are too short for him but he's he's got
great hands he why don't you hook him up
with club I did this Christmas that's
what you finally did because maybe he
would beat you now he's now he's you
know he's got a full-time job as a
basketball player so you're not be
practicing as much I'm worried about it
if you just looked at my guys the Dan
that's their shoes and you were just
trying to fix a lot about yeah a
personality yeah okay
so Paulie got some van surfing shoes
yeah yeah yeah not really good for the
core and then like if you lens right
there yeah these are hiking boots yeah
but if you were picking a golf partner
just based on their shoes I mean you're
in C's Nikes you know that'd be it the
last guy you wouldn't under armours but
yeah the Tim's would be the last guy
that you would want to Nam yeah yeah I
think the give it away yeah I mean
unless he played in them then that well
you actually probably be most qualified
to carry the bag and walk these hills to
be honest okay okay I'm out there and
then you know you could probably have a
couple beverages out there as you're
caddying could be an enjoyable
experience so far sounds like a great
afternoon yeah if we had beverages if
you were playing golf yeah if we had a
Ryder Cup team who's gonna be your
partner
everyone has to yes the dream yeah so
who can hold their liquor and still play
yeah well I don't have that experience
that much experience playing with the
guys out here drinking um I'd probably
choose Rickie Rickie Fowler sneaky
Fowler Nikki long yeah and and he just
like you know he could play barefoot he
could play autumn one foot like he's got
these this skill set
you know I I've played a bit of golf
like that with with him Justin Thomas
myself
me and Justin are awful I'm a drink if
you have yeah awful like it's not
enjoyable for us we play every other
hole we I get the snap hooks he had some
right and we're normally in the same
cards so we just it's it's it's I might
be able to eat it up I might be able to
take you that yeah if we were having
beers yes yeah a bureau whole yeah I'd
get off to a good start against you but
when we flip the turn no it's we're only
playing it's match playing yeah I mean
if I I might have a chance to close you
out but as you start to as we start to
go deeper into the 18 I'm the Golden
Bear of drinking okay yeah so I yeah so
you don't go out like smoke cigars like
we do and have fun like no not normally
I mean but you don't blow for fun dude
I'd rather do that not on a golf course
okay yeah because I just like I can't I
can't mentally you know discharged from
it like I just if I'm out there I feel
like if I hit a bad shot I can't just be
like oh who cares you know I'm I'm like
wait what was wrong why did I
unfortunately because you'll learn to be
able to do maybe yeah yeah you don't
learn here's I was surprised
I shouldn't say surprised but interested
that you were talking to Michael Phelps
like how could he help you I don't know
if that was mentally competitively but
what did you derive from the
conversations with Michael Phelps yes
there's another guy who's just you know
it's it's in kind of an it's an early
success story and it's how you know this
is the greatest Olympian of all time
he's probably the best example of a guy
to chase a ghost and just how do you
keep on resetting those goals and it was
so simple the way he was describing it
was just you know I had my own
records that I I could then go out and
break and you try and relate to that to
golf in a way you know I had these years
or these statistics that I wanted you
know save from 50 to 150 yards I was
this good in proximity one year and
there's a way that you can actually you
know and that was first on tour maybe
last year so how can I even improve on
that you know that's so it's a little
harder to relate to golf but just this
um you know handling spotlight in and
celebrity and you know he's you know
it's a different animal with him that it
is for me but just you know being able
to relate a little bit to that and any
advice I could get from no it's pretty
cool that you're seeking this out just
ya know well it's just like you know I
I've got these opportunities with these
really incredible people that you know
for whatever reason you know golf golf
becomes this sport that these other
athletes turn to after you know their
careers are done and they they love to
try and master it and so they love
playing golf with us and so you know in
return we can then you know learn so
much from them it's just like it's funny
cuz golf is just such a difficult sport
and it you can't master it and it
bothers these guys who have mastered
these other words yeah and and for
whatever reason that brings them closer
to us yeah favorite hole in this course
I love number five actually and the
reason I say everyone says you know six
or seven you know five is a little par
three out here that's just so well
designed it's a newer hole it's a story
of like Chuck Schwab's house they had to
move back because he gave the property
to Pebble and it's just this amazing you
know mid-iron par-3 on the water I
didn't do well in that home no that's
like yeah it's tough to play out of that
like this it's great to see you as
always good luck and defending your
title jordan spieth joining us we're
back after this on the Dan Patrick show
thanks guys for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]